all right welcome to this video back due
to popular demand again the match
against this computer on chess calm
let's see young playing lucky in the
first game itself I came home and here
for some reason playing playing black
iam um I've got a King's Indian
reversed colors this is actually um good
news the computer I think it's not so
great in this type of position
let's see Queen b3 that's not terribly
consistent with them plan to to play um
before
well maybe the computer does not want to
play before okay not quite sure Knight
h4 maybe or to see preparing or what is
it preparing I always have this issue
with it and he and so on tricky okay um
you don't mind that really the straight
it's a closed position but still two
bishops are good to have
okay f4 even weakens the dark squares
enormous leap hmm I don't know should I
take maybe if seven assists under fire a
bit after that
hmmm interesting takes rook takes the
Queen moves and Bishop d5s looks it
looks a bit strange but maybe possible
if I move the Queen away can I get the
Queen away from from f6 it's it's a bit
bit of a tricky spot I wondered f5 ism's
then okay I'll move the Queen uh-huh
this first interesting
yeah that I didn't consider really okay
I cannot easily play Bishop you know
wait I can maybe play Bishop e6 Queen b7
takes takes rook takes Queen b7 and b8
it's probably not bad for me even that
I'm not I'm not sure always it's always
very tricky with this those kind of
tactical lines against the computer
Knight e5 fear maybe Queen a age but
Queenie 8 to get visible between b8
should really be good for me or not or
least okay if I take d5 takes Queen
takes also not bad really
okay Bishop is 5 FV 5
I don't see the big problem right if I
have es I can go 95 or is there
something better f7 is protected at the
moment but it does not make much sense
right so take him okay you know in fact
what I thought was taking and look at
the age there is no big problem with
that
oh I'm poor down yeah which I completely
forgot about I have a point down will ya
the b7 pawn yeah student student German
word creeping into the Coventry I'm
sorry she took this the Joan what for
alright or how that's true okay I'll
take it play rock the 8 to get d5 back I
mean I'm a poor down that's true but I
think I have I have some compensation
maybe not enough compensation but there
is some compensation
that looks a bit bit tricky but there is
some some sort of tactic don't earn who
I'm active suspect really I wonder I
wonder is this bad the drug D - whoopsie
for is a very good response to that
unfortunately
yeah I still need to do it all right see
no other move I always thought I'm a
porn down and I'm not a pawn down I got
one back or am I even counting this
wrong
probably I'm counting it wrong mmm yeah
this is always protect I don't really
know it's tricky to claim you know the
big point is is a big problem a really
big problem the only chances that he
might oh it might play some some wrong
some long trade Knight to Knight to c6
we win it no [ __ ] him I need to warm up
to this it's always tricky business it's
kind of computer matches this was
actually a bit a bit too open maybe
maybe in the French I get get to a close
type of position let's let's see
Oh b6 is quite good news it leads to
very closed positions Bishop a6 about to
come
okay let's think about that that take
should I just take it on
I wonder if f4 as a move but it term
might some temper oh it's not playing
Bishop e6 okay and that is surprising
I'll just play normal moves and keep the
options open form a king I don't want to
Castle short quickly okay yeah because I
was thinking that maybe h4 can be a move
h4 h5 h6 would be very nice but maybe
AFM h4 maybe it's answered by by f6 I
wonder what about Knight to g5 if it if
it plays f6 I take on age 7 and maybe I
can get Queen h5 and if computer plays
h6 I maybe can play h4 for this for this
h-file attack oh really a 5 ok so if I
get will go Queen h5 computer is doing
what exchanging this may be interesting
or here h4 maybe h4 h4 h5 this is a bit
this is dangerous I mean I really think
it's dangerous age 5 okay
any sounds related to beverage is a big
coffee that I made so there is some some
sort of doping going on night f7o can a
not play night f7 here that's very
curious night XG - maybe maybe
oh well what I'm trying to say is night
f7 night xh4 intending night she - maybe
this is the idea okay
well I was I was intending this
originally and I'm going to do it
H takes g5 h take g5 should be too much
okay if I now take here I can take east
six actually six night h4 mean you can
give this check but it's just the check
night is 695 maybe is this year 96 95
maybe but isn't this I wonder okay well
this is just just completely unpractical
for entire computer purposes but maybe I
can just keep the tension here the tech
f2 and ignore this nonsense on the
queenside so night f7 now and then what
does this is what is the response night
h form really oh come on I'm going to
cast along here first I'm going to guess
a long yeah yeah I'll take it
take it I don't mind so what's not now
night f7 then what is this Knight takes
h4 what is response I don't get it
if I just sacrifice on h6 one night f7
night f7 night edge Freud then something
else is there something else I don't
know Knight is 6 it's also looks totally
totally crushing 96 threatening Knights
is 7 as well I really don't see it
anything against the head okay so just
Bishop takes okay Bishop h6 looks
excellent of course but I'd like to get
this first and I really don't see any
okay this one okay hmm okay let's see
how to continue now Bishop h6 it's not
not winning really wait I don't want to
I don't want to draw what I want is to
improve the position a bit threatening
Bishop h6 no threat threatening on e6
okay
can I take only six I can take there one
night age five at night age five is also
quite nice
okay Knight b6 now on the ship g6
let's do Bishop g6 it's certainly not a
bad idea to grab some material mmm oops
I just blended everyone whoops oops okay
no Bishop f7 and this is big threat
ah mr. mermaid I don't see a maid at the
moment I only see the perpetual check
check I don't Queen f6 to it here I
don't know if it will will claim the
draw I don't I don't see a win
unfortunately that's funny I can can
repeat quite a number of times but I
don't see a wind Queen s6 I don't see it
I'm really doing here check again I
don't I don't see a winner probably well
maybe it was some some some quiet move I
don't see it I really don't see it ah
this was a total win a total win okay
but next game I need to I can't get the
right deal into place yeah and so I
computer stuff okay keep it closed keep
it simple number one rule number two
rule
Trading Queens is also quite often a
good good policy maybe a subset of keep
it simple I don't want to trade though
this is not desirable a 8xb it's quite
quite comfortable for white hmm I kept
try to see I'd like to exchange from
this f4 bishop I can try with Bishop d8
no may be 98 Bishop d6 Oh the computer
is not canceling at all yeah I'm not
sure about about c5 if this is an idea I
can't like to prepare you five here yes
because I was suspecting that this is
what's about to come
okay I need to play it at some point I
guess okay well a takes beef gives me a
double pawn hmm yeah that in itself is
not a big deal but the be sure to only
five is a big deal looks very
uncomfortable so I'll take with the
night keeping the the structure in
intact okay
back to D seven I guess
yes mmm a five I don't want to allow a
success looks really uncomfortable like
a 6b 6b should be five that's not a good
idea to allow that the question is
what's my setup now it's fairly healthy
what I have it's it's a tad passive but
it's not like totally passive but
slightly like to get the knight to c6
yeah what rate heart rate I don't mind a
trade really yeah this I can do okay so
if I take our pawn takes looks I look
silly
probably the bishop will take oh okay I
thought this wasn't so great but I
overlooked something I what I thought
this that I will get Bishop to c7 and
detect this and I overlooked that the
computer always can retreat the bishop
and play a form okay but it's playing C
form interestingly enough which I didn't
really consider so what to do maybe the
night I let I let the computer take this
is the best I guess
and now maybe the night the night here
that's a good square it might go to B
form at the text a5 which is very useful
maybe I can actually get the pawn let's
say rook d7 oh I like that that that's
really cute
rook d7 and the bishop over 28 the only
thing might be stupid move like Bishop
c4 Bishop c4 Aria exactly this kind of
concrete moves can sometimes really
spoil your nice long-term idea
I can get the night here though might
sound impossible if I go look to d8
there is maybe six which looks a tad
uncomfortable I would like to play we
should be 78 as well okay
mm-hmm
yeah OOP do you want next
yeah probably I need to do it I don't
don't really see an alternative and now
the computer just drops back okay
very tough tough position I mean tough
not in the sense of that I mean that I
have a problem I don't really think so
but it's not so easy to to evaluate if I
know it's a cave for half what is it
doing dropping her back
no okay if computer playing a phone
maybe
I just said said sir I really don't see
how to improve my position it just looks
looks very passive hmm I'm really not
sure what I did wrong here no this
starts to look really ugly he's six
coming No
welcome to computer chess specially
forum and this is almost one
Wow yeah that's no point and that was
that was really a good position at the
start but then the computer completely
completely outplayed me really tough it
was really good I think a five was weak
and so on but I had no idea where to
improve without looking at it more with
more time and and everything remarkable
it was it was a good position I'm pretty
sure at least for quite quite a while
yeah well this this strange setup the
computer has already tried against me in
in earlier games at least one game and
thankfully enough I won that game I
remember it okay trying to keep good
control over the Queen side and complete
development I could have played before
and maybe I should have played before
it's not a totally big deal home you
know I know the computer actually
invites me to play before stare a reason
not to play it wait before she takes d5
maybe
she takes us you have that's not working
no no okay you always must be super
super cautious that you don't allow
anything anything tactical or simply
blundering stuff
I mean before what I played here it's
maybe I'm not really sure about it I
have a weakened c4 a bit which is not
ideal really yep
that's it's not 100% great really no
better came it's so probably a good
let's say a good playable position
should I take it
yeah probably if I yeah maybe a five
assists already already am on the
horizon
hmm yeah very tricky maybe this is Roxy
one okay yeah the night on g3 is really
not well placed I need to regroup this
piece F 1 D 2 that's that's that's a
possibility to improve it
ok 92
maybe Roxy 7 coming directly if I go B 5
in this position what does a computer
doing B 5 Queen f5 Queen what before
takes takes rook c8
man it's probably not too great on
Bishop d2 not sure I'd really like to
get the Queen's exchange it's it's
always helpful but I'm not I'm not so
I'm not sure about the whole the whole
structure okay I'll do that
Queen with a five Queen platform must
take and rook c8 that's the the problem
or the the point
Knight each eyes he can play it can play
it should be five immediately that's a
problem well I was thinking this one but
okay well that well that was what I
hoped for that this move is necessary if
now if I managed somehow I am that
that's really not possible right
put something on c6
it does not look like it is possible
with him can I get a knight to a three
year no also love possible hmm
yeah that could be could be a problem b5
is completely dependent on this this
night
I need to I need to to play this to set
up set it up like that that creates this
protection and then go like this pile up
on the porn yes that was that was good
that was good it's really a matter of
very very careful play Bishop g5 this is
porn that saying no and no I'm just
going back
okay
what does I didn't see that's a bit a
bit ugly I'm trying to do it of course
get get at the age three porn mmm I
cannot really can do that cannot take is
what I want what's trying to say I
cannot really do that I mean I must know
I must do it now grab the porn but at
the NT to try I would play Bishop d2
that was a bad idea really it was a good
position again really after yet screwed
up his rooks here like rook see some
rugby seven bishops book come to d2 now
and that will be and I must protect it
c3 him can only hope that computer fails
to make any progress but it is not like
it does not look like this is going to
happen right here probably not a good
idea
oh no both rocks swap I know no no no
this so okay well as shoot I shouldn't
have played Bishop g5 this business this
was bad
what's the bit if that's what's about my
hand what did you get the H pawn of
course which it did when that kid's name
- love f5 no I shouldn't have allowed
all that okay
okay I need p7 I really do cannot give
you the spawn okay yeah we're trying to
set up a very compact position hoping to
again keep the position closed okay mom
should i cancel short yeah
maybe a shortened it's hard to do to not
to how to delay that even longer I mean
maybe a move like ballistics just Quinby
seven or something and then be five
maybe okay I would like to keep to play
something like if I've hit but the
computer will probably take him
I can push the the bishop back
now if 5mh our D takes d5 will probably
be played if I Castle there's a form Wow
b5 they're a c5 I had before though it's
not helping a lot
now I canceled before I can actually
take my form so this wasn't so super
dangerous
what about c5 actually takes Knight
takes this shouldn't be so bad really
Knight takes okay maybe if the Queen
moves okay this looks like things are
closing closing up but f4 is probably
the the problem now I didn't play a four
so I actually get the chance to play
Knight to h5 that which I will certainly
take um b5 d7 at the end uh sir hanging
my it would be nice to play be fine
without trading Queens of course I'd be
here and then b5 here we go yeah the
computer might take ed this is what I
suspected or expected Queen f5 which
blunders the decent night no better not
not this one maybe you look b7 man just
dabbling
yeah doubling is not bad if it goes yep
Knight c3 I'm going to okay
Knight c3 I'm going to play Knight f4
okay but the night here so whenever the
bishop takes my position will be
substantially activated with the bishop
on g7 getting alive again okay six rooks
e6 these kinds of moves irritate me
probably with with some reason the
computer might really just look a 1 look
c6 through k-6 just in weight in weight
down that's not so great actually you
know I also have absolutely no attack
here okay I need to try something else
that's the kind of move that really
tough for human opening the position
deliberately but what these six is
hanging okay no okay diem is the problem
probably okay can get to f6 bloody f6
that's a very unattractive and here we
go again yeah
yeah that'sthat's just not I cannot
survive this really windy aid and
everything Co in the end
the 7s look to look a fade okay they
need to be 5 if you need to do
everything like checked 5 times the 5
look totally normal but it just took
everything and look a 6 look c6 and but
then you just toast on the queenside
before b5 I was in really good shape
to be honest a really good anti computer
position ok what what's really
frustrating is that this computer has
such a bad opening book it gets get in
it gets into anti computer stuff all the
time and still escapes
yeah five nine
mmm takes what the poem poor really but
I've forgotten everything here that's
really not good to take with the porn
but I've forgotten how oh I've forgotten
why night takes there is d5 which is not
very comfortable looking mmm but how Qi
can take here and then take you forward
that's also not so great remarkable
and it's not even taking here la
yeah that's about the worst possible
anti computer opening that's that there
is this is just just terrible it's wide
open and it's bad I mean if you have a
wide open position it's probably it it
should be at least a good one
objectively but this is bad and just
terrible against the comp well ugly as
ugly as possible
the only thing maybe I can get somehow
somehow this bishop exchange with Bishop
c5 but this or this Bishop takes d3
business Bishop c5 this this would be
would help
oh just this and Bishop c5 your words
would like to have have a piece there on
c5 I mean not the Queen yeah I'm not
saying that I'm in good shape but I
think I've seen worse in this game it
was it was even even worse here at least
have some sort of blockage here
maybe it's my mother no tricky tricky as
usual without the king can come over the
king can always come over
is it helpful to play this I don't know
okay
yeah of course can always get the bishop
over here maybe Knight a six a threat
the gunite is six no that are not okay
threatening I'm really surprised that
there is some kind of game still going
on night here is the Gypsy seven can I
somehow ninety seven bishops see seven
if no way to attack this right
I wonder ever somehow can attack the
pawn two times would be immensely
helpful of course maybe try to win it
even okay all night and Bishop to b4 but
at the moment I'm not seeing how the
computer is actually making any big
headway I go night here be sure before
check bishops III there is what exactly
not sure
okay if I take it to now there is
probably c5 yeah that's very
uncoordinated maybe this someone
this check here since the king to e7
won't Bishop back here why not I try and
then then the shake but I'll get the
porn I don't really want to take and the
lousy fire the sucess looks wrong Bishop
now and then actually the King comes to
be six it's not whatever wand we divide
what if I switch over to g7
okay I must I must speed up things I can
easily get into some sort of nasty pin
like that that's very very very very
tricky now
bishop to a form
it's brutal
I think they didn't even play well this
isn't game but it was yeah okay it was
too much or too too too bad this time
this is the solo position it was just
too open okay let's see
okay I don't I don't really want how to
get this maybe this one that could be a
good idea actually trying to get rid of
this LightSquared bishop and then try to
set up on light square complex yeah yeah
that's that's it's pretty good
it looks like a decent and I compute a
position with the Metis being totally
closed okay III is very good news
computer weakens his King position
Knights you for me just yeah but let's
come here must be must still be very
cautious there there might be some some
sacrificial stuff coming here okay
so if I go if if was very closed before
before 94 this does not look totally
convincing maybe I should retreat the
Queen
so that Knight f4 is not so easily
possible okay so this was probably a
good choice before maybe no I wonder if
I should retreat the noid just retreat
it b3 b3 it's of course yeah it is good
but you can easily force things to too
quickly here I'm not not sure because of
that okay all this this is good but not
sure if it was the the the the process
the book the best possible outcome takes
or not probably takes the knight over to
d5 is the the best possible scenario
let's do that
okay well that's a very very very good
position but it still has you can still
screw it up
I must I must cancel of course I mean
get the King King out here can I should
I play h6 age 6 g 5 Bishop means why
just look before my checking a phone I
could also play Bishop e7 now takes
bishop takes I come on this
I know it's my good Bishop but I need to
get my stuff coordinated here
castles always the really some
counter-attack against my king I that's
hard to believe ready
maybe if maybe g6 first okay Castle I
mean I don't believe in any
counter-attack Queen aged six I have g6
the computer might play Queen g5 but ok
then I'll trade the Queen's whatever
now queen a6 there is no no great come
to play that's some sort of some sort of
air for the king queen a7 and that's a
good attacking deform
now look b3 exchange one rook and
possibly get rook before Queen d7 again
seven okay if I take it there is a
counter play takes takes Queen g6 hmm if
I take on f5 and computer takes with the
Queen that's a very good rogue and game
I don't I don't mind that
so okay takes and then should i okay if
I'm not trade let's start with that
Queen b7 no let's just try it and now
let's have a look at this I can play you
cannot get to the d5 pawn with a six I
take with the tempo Ruki v king of seven
that's totally fine I can get I can take
a four that's one thing and I can play
c3 c3 and but then the slope no I won't
add I just want a four for the moment
and then improve further
okay if I go look a - yeah maybe the the
king is the problem no I go here and
play a form but that's totally ok if the
King goes to c3 I'm giving this check
and I'm winning and my next steps are
okay oh is this not winning if I'm
taking a 3 that would be bloody unfair
taking a king goes all the way to before
and takes the pawn I'll be damned
really No
I don't see I don't see an alternative
can't believe this nonsense no so I
played a wrong wrong sort of thing I can
I can do that but it might be risky I
know but I want I want it doesn't take
it the computer just just not take it
g6 maybe that's a bad idea
yeah but the real nuisance is this that
that that this is even possible rook
takes and then the King goes to the a
pawn
that'sthat's really pretty disappointing
okay
this was this was really completely
completely winning position but this
thing this thing has offended well yeah
usually I play until I get a winnin but
it hasn't materialized yet I really want
to win here again one of those silly
non-computer openings I mean they come
what I'm trying to say is the computer
is playing a setup that it really plays
badly but still need to exploit it
yeah this is a bit strange the Queen on
a5 and everything um okay this this is
very good news
I want it blocked they don't want the
Kings side to open so I'm going to play
G form and you're not going to play b5 I
really don't think so okay I want Knight
f1 g3 but at the moment there is mighty
form we need to cover that
okay well the next step is to cut in h4
h5 okay computer plays g5 without being
provoked so I'm going to get an edge for
here so that's nice it will play Knight
FA to g6 so I'll close this I don't I
don't mind that because the the game
will be decided on the on the other side
of the board
b5 s the computer really playing b5 here
maybe
so I have completely sealed the kingside
and there's nothing happening over there
and the next step is of course to open
up the queenside I think I can go before
now there's no no drawback if I take now
here no no not a good idea you can I can
still improve things the night on g3 is
always ready to hop into f5 at the right
moment if I take might be fire that
wouldn't be bad if also wouldn't be bad
okay I know I just put it there but hmm
I have some idea
I think I can do this no I'm pretty sure
to get an 85 which is happening now
okay fatigue now here my to be five not
sure that I played it in the best
possible way I'm really not sure about
that but it's not certainly not bad I
would like to get in the bishop in to
play my bishop to a for this this would
be really nice
let me get this however if you know I
turn I need to cover d3 what no don't
tell me this is possible now I keep
doing everything to prevent that why is
this possible takes and then what you
form what if I take on c5 first take on
g4 what I take that first one so and now
with the night or with the pawn if I
take with the pawn that's what g4 hmm
yeah that's not really working
okay I still want to make sure that it's
absolutely never happening this movie
form how could I do that night on g4
would be nice
can I can I get this in maybe get the
Queen over first here so that this is
protected over protect b5 and now the
night all the way over okay if I go here
that's Knight f6 and I cannot protect it
and that's bad
okay
I know this is super slow what I'm doing
like over protecting everything three
times but I want to be I want to be
cautious like like to the utmost yeah
take now it does not really help to keep
it totally blocked I would need a bishop
here on 1g form I take now I mean it's
sufficiently safe I think really but no
look is seven entering didn't even think
about getting getting the King 2g form
as strange as it may look but wait I can
actually put I can really do that
put the bishop
I put the bishop to h3 and this this
could be a good play an idea what will
it will kick no it will kick him I look
out maybe this isn't so helpful after
all I really I'd like to get the bishop
the bishop there would be really nice
the Queen there but I can go to g4
already maybe I should do that don't do
with the King to g4 everything else
fails okay now I get this in that's
that's nice okay well this is now
totally totally safe and I have this f6
move at the right moment this is the key
to to this I believe okay and I could
have played repaid hmm miss this chance
I exchanged something here
this is really totally blocked there's
absolutely nothing happening I hope I
hope the light squares other are the big
problem now will be eight or something
yeah I don't think this is really
winning but I probably don't make any
progress elsewhere okay and now the only
thing to try is to get the king all the
way over as could be a winner in him it
could be yeah I think this is a winner
really yep
Wow Wow
this was tough like doing the slow
motion chess really
108 moves
Wow
127 moves whoo
so playing to the first win and this
time it took one hour 15 minutes so I
did score two draws and this win had
some pretty good positions I think there
was really more possible I guess but
yeah you don't know you never know
didn't lose yeah they were one or two
really bad ones but okay I'm satisfied
this was quite a quite a nice um last
game all right thank you for watching
and I'll be back with this kind of
content regularly I really enjoy it from
time to time just play this kind of slow
mo chess against the computer okay
thanks for watching